hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play vanish
now you guys may know I don't like this
game very much for multiple reasons
mainly that it's really good and it's
random which I don't like but I'm gonna
play it anyway and I've got the volume
turned up extra loud just for your
entertainment I'm gonna make a real
concerted effort to beat this because
apparently there is an ending that I can
find but I don't wanna get gave me
nightmares last time I swear I don't
know what it is like I've said it before
it's that it creates a sense of dread
and that's that is really really truly
what makes a horror game good and I'm a
big baby I'm a big whiny baby big whiny
baby oh man
I'm sure I'm cranking up the volume even
more just so I can really get that
immersion going not that I need any help
okay so I know that I got to get to the
first place with the notes and the
instructions but once I get to that room
I have no idea where to go because this
place fricking changes which is by far
one of the coolest features I've seen in
a horror game but that doesn't mean that
I like it he made any money out of it
I'm coming down the most brightly lit
one but it also was one with flickering
lights on it I'd snap bad just a pipe
just a pipe it's okay let's take a
breather here I gotta keep in mind that
my character is just
which way which way back out
okay all right we're fine we're fine
crisis averted we're fine
I think we may not be fine but I have no
idea okay we're still in the loo I was
just about to stay I literally was about
to say we're still in the lit portion
god damn you came it's like you're in my
brain I love you so much
stop a beaut life you know no was he no
say there's something definitely
following me I swear if that's you feel
I'm gonna kill you please don't kill me
I would not like that very much god this
game is so reminiscent of the first time
I played STP oh wait seven B which is
the stairwell game but I've said that
before you all know what I'm talking
about okay I gotta beat this game you
know it's pretty bad I haven't even seen
goddamnit I was just saying I haven't
seen a single monster yet I literally
was just saying that [ __ ] yo game
that whispering is new I don't remember
hearing that I don't like this game
hi that's new that's very new okay okay
the whispering did that happen before it
but a while since I've played this oh
I'm not gonna make it to the end am i
I'm not gonna win because even in SC poh
7b it was a pattern that you could
understand it feels like I'm walking in
circles out of the walls are moving on
me where the hell is the water pump room
again Phil oh god I don't know where the
water pump room is you dick I don't even
know where I am right now
Oh
JG me oh no good just stare I shot
shut up right there it's red hair okay
it's not there maybe it was there I
don't know maybe it was I don't know but
this son of a [ __ ] is not gonna kill
they okay
it's not gonna kill me why why do you do
that I don't know why that is that thing
that it does what is the ahh
I don't know what that is is this still
there if it's still there you son of a
[ __ ] I'm gonna stab you in the groin oh
stop it
oh I'll stab you in your okay all right
don't panic
it's not there it's not really there
that's all lies it's all just lies what
is this what the hell is this this is
not a map oh my god this is not a map of
any kind that can help me you're all
sons of [ __ ] I hate you so much and I
watch y'all go die in a pit of fire burn
in hell the whispering is getting a bit
more intense okay that always like
totally boned cuz that guy's not going
away I probably got far enough away to
get the walls to move I don't know I
don't know how this game works
Oh know how this game works I don't know
how this game works
I don't know all I know is that I need
to keep moving forward until I can find
a water pump room but I haven't even
found that generator room
what no how am I in the beginning can I
get out look at look at this is this is
not how I started
why my vinegar wibbly-wobbly my vision
went super wibbly-wobbly what happened
what happened what's going on
what is it happen a way to me I think I
just gotta keep it
okay humor I'm gonna flood lamp with ha
I'm not back in the beginning ah crap I
am back in the beginning eating any
money this way not down the dark way no
way in hell screw you
what is going on
don't you haha me
don't haha me
don't use jockey don't do anything just
everybody shut up
I died
melissa has a quick death I didn't even
see it coming
ah okay okay okay all right I'm done
thank you watching
all right more here we go sorry
oh I don't like this game
okay here we go we got spread throughout
we're gonna sprint and it's gonna be
great we're gonna go real fast and it's
gonna be awesome
because no one's gonna expect it we're
gonna sneak up on them and we're gonna
scare them in there and no not good I
can't even come oh I'm out of breath
already I can't even do commentary on
this game no none of that
screw you go die in hell go the hell and
you die oh my god ah did I just nort a
line of the Scarecrow's fear stuff Jesus
Christ you know that fear powder I just
laid it on table cut it up and it yeah
alright let's go in the sores that's a
great idea
haha with the mole people alright god
I'm such a freakin idiot I keep going in
here I just go straight this time Oh
save your running juice for when the
monsters come out oh man this guy has to
be on some kind of drugs to be going
back in here I mean screw your friends
buddy who cares at this point just
abandon them go home live to fight
another day they're already eaten by the
mole people
they're all dead you're alive yeah
whatever
no one ever listens to reasoning these
horror games no one ever listens to
reason but then that's what makes it a
horror game people make stupid decisions
all the time which leads them into death
and destruction they're got a new God my
closet is open all your liar you're a
liar arrow
that's no okay all right okay all right
let's go towards a noise that's a great
idea
one another good great idea for the
stockpile I swear my closet was not open
when I started this game oh don't you
shush ami okay what did that note say
check the what I I can't get to that's
new
where's annoys they're not new I'm just
saying they're new back to back
I'm not back let me get it
I'm not back nothing I'm not I got a
note I'm not back in the beginning Hank
are you here you're getting notes thank
you ah don't look back why oh it's good
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die and it's
gonna be so freaking awesome
stop chattering that okay usually
usually something appears by day when I
redid that end okay just noises just
stupid noises just stupid noises it's
nothing serious
nothing I need to worry about I'm fine I
am just freaking fine why why why why
why why what not that way not that way
not that way not that way not that way
not that way not that way you know if I
was in this sewer with more people I
would not stop running until I was dead
oh look it's a hidey hole I can like it
we can hide from them ah I feel safe for
once in my life oh I hate them sick oh
if you were dead end I was gonna stab
you in the butt oh it's good boy if you
were oh god it's a maze don't cave in on
me bro
I just realized something
these holes are made by those things so
there's a high possibility I'll see one
in here I kind of just realized that
okay alright whatever
cool cool bro cool story bro cool story
bro good job alright mate it helps stop
that
that's not cool bro shut up I know
you're just noises now you're not gonna
get me that could get me I'm too smart
too smart for you way too smart and
handsome and strong you're just noises
noises in my head I'm not going crazy
you're a bunch of liars
liars and dirty cheats lie the letter
net lies lies lies lies lies lies and
dirty cheats lies lies lies lies
I how am I ever gonna find the water
pump from I don't even know where I am
oh oh oh I want to go home I wanna go
why why'd you do that why did you do
that
why why why did you do that why I did do
that why'd you do that there's some
behind me
this is on Muhammad why did you do that
why did you do that
home I want to go home
oh my god I wanted to find the bump room
god damn it it's like what if I had
something let me find something
give me some hold on No
but now I maybe my heart just exploded
hey this gift talk yeah okay you are
okay all right you know what ha ha and
then I'm done
excuse me I'm done forever
I'm never gonna beat this game I'm not
gonna play it again so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I won't see you in
the next video bye
you go back there are you sure those it